we will get to those stories in just a
moment but first take a look at this a
tragic situation
unfolding this is in the southwest part
of the valley tonight
traffic on westbound 215 being diverted
off the freeway at decatur after a
deadly crash there
thanks for joining us at 11 o'clock i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis nhp
saying this is a hit-and-run crash
involving a tow truck driver
8 news now reporter orco mano live now
with more on this incident
orco well brian denise it is a very
active scene here just taking a look
behind me you can see that nevada hybrid
patrol
is out here investigating this deadly
hit and run crash
we have several nhp vehicles out here
and as you mentioned a tow truck driver
is involved in this that tow truck
driver being hit
by a vehicle that was driving west here
on westbound 215 and joining us to give
us a little more detail
about what exactly happened with this
tow truck driver we have nhp trooper
trooper travis smacka trooper smack tell
us a little bit about this
tow truck driver was working on the
shoulder correct yes he was
the preliminary details we have at this
time is approximately 7 47 p.m we
responded to a call of a
auto pedestrian hit run crash what we
know now
is that a suspect vehicle was westbound
on the southern beltway approaching
jones as you see behind me
when for reasons unknown it drifted into
the right shoulder striking a tow truck
driver
as well as a tow truck before fleeing
the scene without stopping
the tow truck driver was transported to
umc trauma where he succumbed to
injuries sustained in the crash and was
pronounced deceased
and you said we are still looking for
the driver who
crashed into this tow truck driver you
were looking for a specific kind of
vehicle can you describe that to me in
other
details about what you know about that
vehicle yes
the vehicle we are looking for is
witnesses are describing
a white box van possibly a ford with
right front damage
and anybody that knows anything about
this horrible
fatal crash this tragedy please contact
star
hp or crime stoppers
we really need your help on this one
this is a
man who has a family who won't have a
chance to get home tonight
because someone failed to obey the move
over law and then fled the scene
and again you are still searching for
that driver trooper smacking thank you
so much for joining us really appreciate
it
so again nhp is still investigating this
deadly hit and run crash you heard
trooper smacka say
they are looking for the driver of what
appears to be a white
box van potentially a ford so if you
have any information
you're asked to call nhp of course stay
with 8 news now both on air and online
for the latest details for now reporting
live orco mana 8 news now
in that white box van with front right
damage orco thank you